voilà donc pour cette audition de jean
castex le monsieur déconfinement du
gouvernement audition en commission
spéciale
vous connaissez peut-être ce décor du
rouge du noir un logo c'est ça vous
regarde
on est ravi de vous retrouver bonsoir à
tous on est vraiment très heureux de ce
retour du direct sur la chaîne
parlementaire toute la rédaction toute
la chaîne est ravi de ce retour à
l'antenne l'émission s'est adapté mais
le plaisir vous allez le voir est
toujours là au sommaire ce soir alors à
quoi sert le parlement dont cette crise
sans précédent malgré les contraintes
les députés ont siégé et ont voté l'état
d'urgence et sa prolongation
mais avec quelle marge de manoeuvre dans
un moment où le gouvernement concentre
les pouvoirs l état de droit est il
respecté l'assemblée peut-elle rester
sous cloche la marcheuse aurore bergé à
débattre avec le socialiste boris ballot
et puis les politiques des politiques
dans notre pays ont-ils le droit à
l'erreur à la défiance grandi à l'égard
d' emmanuel macron alors que les
boulettes de donald trump semble glisser
sur lui pourquoi certains pays font bloc
malgré un nombre de morts plus important
que chez nous le réflexe de division et
ils typiquement français l'éclairage de
nos invités à suivre enfin un nouveau
rendez vous le jour d'après chaque soir
un grand entretien autour d'un thème au
coeur de l'épidémie ce soir l'école
quelles leçons tirer ces deux mois de
classe à la maison yanis rôdeur
professeur d'histoire géographie en
seine saint denis répond à nos questions
voilà vous savez tout est axé vers ça ça
n'a pas changé c'est parti
[Musique]
et bienvenue à vous chers
téléspectateurs merci d'avoir choisi lcp
bonsoir aurore bergé
merci d'être là pour ce retour à
l'antenne vous êtes député la république
en marche des yvelines porte parole du
groupe majoritaire à l'assemblée en face
de vous boris balle au bond soit merci à
vous d'être la députée socialiste des
landes
et puis richard wehrli quel plaisir de
vous retrouver richard alors vous
connaissez les règles strictes
ici comme ailleurs il faut qu'il y ait
des invités il y en aura de nombreux ce
soir derrière leur écran merci richard
chroniqueur dans cette émission
correspondant du quotidien suisse le
temps
à quoi servent les députés ce que vous
êtes frustrés dans cette période de ne
pas assez pesé
je vous pose la question dans un instant
est ce qu'il a été mise entre
parenthèses ce palais bourbon
c'est vous qui allez vous y coller en
premier mon cher stéphane savourer bien
la petite oreillette
allez c'est parti si j'ai bien solide
[Musique]
reposez manifestement stéphane blakowski
alors si j'ai bien compris pour le
parlement pas de répit c'est ça surtout
si j'ai bien compris
myriam à l'assemblée nationale on est
sur le retour du chemin qui mène vers la
normale le retour à la normale variait
une partie du personnel qui est donc en
plateau comme vous les députés sont plus
en plus nombreux dans l'hémicycle
bref tout petit à petit on recommence
exactement comme avant alors évidemment
d'un côté c'est une bonne nouvelle
et en même temps est-ce que c'est une
bonne idée on en avait parlé de la même
l'avènement d'un monde nouveau est ce
que l'assemblée doit pas montrer
l'exemple puisque doit prouver qu'il est
elle aussi de se réinventer
alors évidemment c'est jamais facile de
se remettre en cause
on est obligé de se poser des questions
qu'on s'était jamais posée par exemple
est-ce qu'un député c'est aussi
indispensable qu'une caissière qu'un
éboueur où je sais pas qu'un policier
dans la tension ne me faites pas dire ce
que j'ai pas dis hein c'est pas ça c'est
très très utile d'un député beaucoup
plus utile qu'un chroniqueur télé ça il
a aucun doute là dessus c'est parce que
je veux dire c'est que pendant la crise
on a fonctionné avec beaucoup moins de
députés et finalement ça s'est passé
mais exactement comme d'habitude
simon résume avant la crise l'opposition
reproché au gouvernement quoi d'accuser
des ordonnances de pas les seules formes
débattre bref ne pas respecter le
parlement est donc là pendant la crise
qu'est ce qui s'est passé bat road
ordonnance réforme des bacs respecte pas
le parlement a rien n'a changé à nancy
on veut que ça change
il fait plus ambitieux je vois si vous
souvenez il y avait des projets de
réforme des institutions au début du cac
est là et il y avait un député à
l'époque elle aime une contribution
intéressante s'appelle adrien attaques
émanant du gouvernement et à l'époque il
avait quasiment un projet visionnaire
puisque la première étape c'était une
assemblée virtuel où on développerait
bas les réunions en visioconférence
peut-être même le vote à distance par
bref tous les outils numériques alors là
ils avaient vraiment icp le coup parce
que depuis quelques semaines on a fait
des gros progrès à l'assemblée là dessus
mais sa deuxième idée donc puisqu'il est
visionnaire écoutons le
ils disaient les sillons délocalisait
l'assemblée en province bah ouais
pourquoi pas
symboliquement ce serait fort ça
prouverait que toutes les décisions ne
se prennent pas uniquement à paris puis
alors hip hop c'est compliqué c'est très
simple dès que le parlement européen
sera transférée à bruxelles l'hémicycle
sera dispo à strasbourg on pourra
réinstaller l'assemblée à strasbourg bon
je dis pas que c'est vraiment la
solution parfaite
au moins ça prouvera qu'en france tous
ne recommence pas comme avant merci
merci stéphane vous restez avec nous
vous pouvez réagir quand quand vous le
souhaitez on va parler bien sûr du rôle
du parlement dans cette crise parce que
vous n'avez pas rien faire je lui dit
d'entrée de jeu mais on va voir ce qui
s'est passé qu'est ce que vous pensez
avoir berger l'idée de stéphane plus de
visioconférence à l'avenir tirer des
leçons
c'est ce qu'on a fait quand même
beaucoup pendant deux mois après je
pense que enfin le travail de manière
générale ne peut pas entièrement se
construire de manière dématérialisée
c'est aussi du lien social
le fait qu'on puisse être ensemble et
travailler ensemble
je pense que ça aide aussi à construire
des solutions qui sont aussi plus
efficace vient ne vaut au fond le
contact physique la discussion il faut
évidemment qu'on puisse tirer des
enseignements de ce qui s'est passé y
compris sur le mode de fonctionnement de
l'assemblée y compris en effet sur la
capacité à voter à distance de manière
individuelle amendement par amendement
et ça je pense que c'est des choses
qu'il faudrait en effet qu'ils puissent
aboutir et aboutir beaucoup plus vite
donc ça oui après je pense que rien ne
remplace quand même malgré tout le fait
qu'on soit physiquement ensemble vous
avez l'impression d'avoir changé votre
rôle pendant cette période franchement
un rêve d'être à la hauteur
un fond du débat démocratique nécessaire
mais tout dépend déjà de ce qu'est un
député de quelle est la définition qu'on
en donne
et de fait notre rôle il a été très
différent il a été différent parce que
on a été deux fait des saisies de par
l'état d'urgence sanitaire des
prérogatives qui sont habituellement les
nôtres et donc on a beaucoup moins
légiférer on a habilité le parlement a
le gouvernement pardon à légiférer à
notre place est évidemment il va falloir
aussi que ça c'est certain
c'est frustrant ça j'imagine c'est
frustrant mais non c'est à dire que on
comprend que dans une période qui est
une période complètement exceptionnel il
faille à un moment accepter qu'on puisse
aller plus vite sur un certain nombre de
décisions
et est-ce que ça a permis d'aller plus
vite je le crois notamment sur
l'activité partielle sur le fond
solidarité etc
est-ce que ça doit s'arrêter un jour oui
évidemment il plutôt le mieux parce que
le parlement
oui c'est utile et c'est la garantie et
le respect des libertés publiques et de
la démocratie de la représentation des
français on habilite le gouvernement
est-ce qu'on pèse sur le fond parce que
on a l'impression d'apporter sa pierre
même si elle est toute petite
alors peut-être que c'est aussi
différent je pense qu'on est dans la
majorité ou qu'on est dans l'opposition
et je pense qu'on vit pas la période
tout à fait de la même manière pour être
très honnête ce qui est certain c'est
que nous on a vu notre nos liens avec
l'exécutif beaucoup plus s'affermir
pendant cette période ça peut paraître
très contradictoires mais les relations
n'ont jamais été aussi fluide dans cette
période parce qu'en fait il ya eu un
besoin évident de s'appuyer sur les
retours que nous on avait très concret
des artisans des commerçants des
agriculteurs des artistes des tpe des
pme des enseignants enfin toutes celles
et ceux qui à la fois soit été en
première ligne souhaitait en première
ligne pour aussi subir la crise et avait
besoin d'accompagnement vous étiez à la
manoeuvre pourriez dire ça en tout cas
ce qui est certain c'est qu'il ya un
certain nombre de dispositifs soient
qu'il n'aurait pas existé soit qu'ils
n'auraient pas été modifiées si que les
parlementaires n'ont pas vous n'avez pas
poussé le fonds de solidarité ou départ
c'était 70 % de baisse de chiffre
d'affaires s'est passé à 50
le fait de pouvoir poursuivre l'activité
partielle au delà du mois de mai ça
aussi il est question du tourisme de la
culture
il ya vraiment des sujets dont on s'est
emparé et à des sujets ou en effet c'est
vrai c'est le gouvernement qui a eu la
main dessus
c'est aussi votre avis vous avez vécu
des choses de la même manière député
socialiste dans l'opposition on a tous
été la courroie de transmission de ce
qui nous était répétée sur le terrain
les commerçants les artisans la formule
des propositions sur le tourisme sur
tous les sujets qui ont été évoqués on a
eu des retours on a formulé des
propositions mais la chronique était
très juste au fond ce que nous avons
vécu comme un puissance dont la crise on
l'a constaté déjà avant les ordonnances
le sentiment de faire de la figuration
qu'on a un déséquilibre institutionnel
qui place le parlement dans un état de
faiblesse
je vais dire structurelles et qui
appelle des réformes institutionnelles
lourdes pas celle qui était proposé au
début du quinquennat
un vrai rééquilibrage au profit du
parlement qui pose la question de la
délibération citoyenne et la place des
électeurs mais je me souviens des
attentats et de françois hollande qui
avait lui même décrété l'état d'urgence
et je me souviens de cette majorité
vous étiez entre guillemets dans cette
majorité vous travaillez même allé
l'idée à l'époque
vous auriez fait différemment
franchement il a été fait différemment
il a été fait du
vraiment je vous donne un exemple au
moment où ont été votés le l'état
d'urgence en matière terroriste
la commission des lois de l'assemblée
nationale a imposés à sa propre à son
propre gouvernement que 7000 cette
commission soit transformé en commission
d' enquête et que les pouvoirs d'une
commission denquête de double enquête
sur pièces et sur place avec un travail
qui a été accompli pendant deux ans qui
est très extrêmement méticuleux
là on a demandé à ce que la mission
d'information soit une commission
denquête ça nous a été refusée moi je
leur demande il faut que la mission
d'information aujourd'hui sur locaux
vides soit une commission denquête parce
qu'on ne peut pas se satisfaire d'avoir
plus d'informations par la presse que
dans notre travail de contrôle
parlementaire berger sur ce pouvoir de
contrôle à défaut de pouvoir aux font
peser sur le fond sur des propositions
de loi sur des amendements
vous avez ce pouvoir de contrôle de
l'exécutif pourquoi pas une commission
denquête à mesure que voilà la crise est
gérée
ce qui est certain c'est que le pouvoir
de contrôle en vérité et les faibles
enfin il est faible de manière enfin
constitutionnellement en vérité il l'est
déjà allés les pouvoirs sont faibles sur
ce sujet là à l'assemblée et nous on a
faim on a été élus au même moment et
finalement je pense qu'on a tous
constaté la faiblesse structurelle qui
était celle de l'assemblée dans ses
capacités de contrôle parce que nous
n'avons pas les moyens humains
financiers aussi de pouvoir bien faire
et de pouvoir bien conduire ce travail
là parce que on a aussi des études
d'impact qui arrive qui souvent arrive
tard qui souvent ne sont pas suffisantes
pour pouvoir vraiment juger et c est ça
ces constats là ils sont très partagés
quelles que soient nos bancs majorité ou
opposition pressent qu'il faut une que
l'info plus de contrôler plus de
pouvoirs pour le mener ici car le mans
souvent on pense que ça c'est une vraie
nécessité démocratique et encore une
fois ça repositionne la question la
soutenait avec moi l'idée de transformer
la mission d'information concernant je
ne sais pas si ça permettra d'avoir
moins la conviction que j'ai dans le
moment qu'on est en train de vivre
il ya la question institutionnelle moi
je fais partie de ceux qui pensent la
vème république était à bout de souffle
qu'elle est devenue pathologiquement
incapable créer du débat de fabriquer du
compromis de laisser de la place à
unisys et parlement quart temps de crise
alors là là mais en temps de crise c'est
que plus vrai encore c'était déjà le
débat pendant la grande guerre il y
avait janet clemenceau violette
à taez contre le gouvernement ils
retenaient pas leurs coûts mais on peut
dire que dans la grande guerre le
parlement aussi à gagner rires eh bien
moi je crois que dans le moment que nous
vivons
on sait pas ce qui va à quoi ressemblera
le monde d'après ya des utopies
autoritaire ya des guerres de modèle
politique dans la gestion du duc au vide
et bien on a besoin d'être extrêmement
exigeant plus qu'on ne l'a jamais été
sur le respect des libertés publiques
sur le libre et le respect des droits
constitutionnels sur la place du
parlement
et je crois que s'agissant notamment de
l'habilitation à légiférer par
ordonnance il faut pas aller au delà
là on a dans la semaine à une ordonnance
à examiner 33e deux ordonnances des
habilitations pour un an 30 mois y a pas
d'urgence si ces trente mois il n'y a
pas d'urgence
si c'est un an mais qu'est ce que vous
craignez pas ce que je regarde les
ordonnances là c'est le texte qui arrive
jeudi
donc on a déjà un paquet ordonnance dans
l'état d'urgence mais là il y en a un
nouveau paquet en dehors de l'état
d'urgence sanitaire report de l'entrée
en vigueur de mesures d'expérimentation
mesures pour faire face aux difficultés
de fonctionnement des juridictions
mesures sur les indemnisations des
victimes des essais nucléaires c'est
très divers prolongation des mesures
relatives au seuil de revente à faire
tout ça c'est nécessaire de le faire
maintenant absolument barrages sont un
moyen qui court circuite de fait le
parlement qui le court circuite oui non
puisque nous mêmes on va en débattre et
la roque à une commission spéciale qui a
commencé le débat et moi je serai jeu
c'est justement cette semaine donc on va
en débattre après on peut aussi décider
qu'un certain nombre de choses ne
doivent pas passer par ordonnance et
doivent être inscrits dans le dur de la
loi il ya des courses si tu finalistes
qui vous disent aujourd'hui pas tout ça
mais certains autant donner les pleins
pouvoirs je suis évidemment par un je
suis pas constitutionnaliste mais en
tant que parlementaire évidemment je
pourrais pas me satisfaire du fait qu'on
accorde les pleins pouvoirs et je pense
que c'est évidemment pas ça qu'il en est
mais vous voyez bien que les ordonnances
elles sont de nature très divers dans
celle qu'on a examiné elles vont autant
sur des enjeux d'activité partielle sur
le fait qu'ils puissent d'intéressement
par exemple pour les salariés c'est à
dire des choses immédiate des décisions
qu'on doit prendre tout de suite pour
faire face à la crise et sur une crise
en effet dont on sait que
vraisemblablement elle va durer en tout
cas elle va pas durer que quelques
semaines supplémentaires
mais de toute façon l'état d'urgence
sanitaire il doit s'arrêter
il est prévu de s'arrêter de toute façon
10 juillet voit la mi juillet on a voté
la prorogation de cette aide d'urgence
ce qui veut dire aussi que le parlement
décide d'y mettre un terme
et donc qu'à partir de là
c'est nous qui devons aussi reprendre la
main sur le calendrier sur les priorités
il ya aussi un certain nombre de niches
parlementaires qui vont exister dire
c'est que la validité des ordonnances la
validité donc de de ce travail qui va
être fait par l'exécutif en lieu et
place du parlement qui s'est dessaisi de
ses pouvoirs là il va pas s'arrêter avec
l'état d'urgence mais ils sont deux
calendriers différents faut quand même
l'avoir en tête et donc oui c'est
extrêmement préoccupant ou nantes en ce
moment on entend votre inquiétude crois
que stéphane qui va jouer c'était un
truc tu es fan non moi je me tenais mais
je l'air de prendre parti mais je
m'étonne aussi sur le le fait que le
gouvernement se donne le bras pendant un
an de légifération une quantité
incroyable de sujets sans jamais
consulter le parlement c'est étonnant
surtout quand on dit que la ville et du
théâtre et du pied c'est ce que disait
robert julien est ce que la ville
d'opposition et d'inutile non je crois
pas qu'elle dise ah ça non plus donc
c'est bizarre ces douze mois
c'est même jusqu'à 30 mois pour un
certain nombre de mesures liées aux
briques site
oui c'est quand même c'est quand même
beaucoup trop moi je crois qu'on est
dans un moment qu'il faut prendre avec
gravité il ya un certain nombre de
choses et en particulier la démocratie
et à doha qui sont pas des évidences il
faut être extrêmement exigeants et
chacun en est comptable et chacun doit
être vigilent je crois qu'on l'a été et
d'ailleurs pas bon pour reprendre un
exemple parce que ça a beaucoup occupé
nos débats y compris au sein de la
majorité sur par exemple la question de
l'application stop qu'ovide du conseil
conçue en elle là a dit un certain
nombre de choses d'ailleurs et un
certain nombre de réserves
on a été nombreux au sein de la majorité
et moi également à dire les réserves
très clair et très net qu'on avait et
qui nécessitaient qu'il y ait un débat
dédié qu'il y ait un vote dédié et que
ça ne pouvait pas se confondre avec la
déclaration du premier ministre et
d'ailleurs c'est bien ce qu'ils aient
lieu à dire qu'il n'ya pas eu de
confusion sur les deux enjeux parce que
sinon on l'avait dit très clairement que
nous n'étions pas suffisamment à l'aise
pour pouvoir justement voter sur ces
sujets c'est un exemple qui montre
justement jeunes et aussi dans gala on
sait pas sur la glace et les diverses un
exemple plus pertinent puisque dans la
mesure où
le gouvernement envisage et
l'application et ovh tour l'application
stop trop vite comme un des éléments de
la stratégie n'est pas donné le débat
aurait pu être mon conjoint
le héros du jour a été changé 24 heures
avant que les parlementaires et c'est
vrai qu'on est allé terminer plus
l'application diffusion c'est un
cinquième journée de sujets mais pas été
satisfaisant non plus qu'on ait laissé
ce qu'on ait changé l'ordre du jour et
qu'on essaie un peu tout intéressant
vous parliez de cette application dont
pour l'instant c'est pas ce top cow vide
c'est un fichier un fichier de malades
et de l'entourage de ce malade doit il
être différent mise en place par les
médecins généralistes avec ses fameuses
brigades d assurance maladie qui vont
essayer de retrouver et les entourages
pour casser les chaînes de contamination
y en a un qui estime que le parlement il
a été complètement respecté et même au
delà c'est le ministre de la santé
lévis vers ans et coûté 2 c'était
justement dans l'hémicycle au sujet de
cette discussion sur ce fichier de
malades il faut arrêter de nous comparer
à la corée à singapour à l'allemagne le
débat qu'on a là on est le seul payé là
bas c'est très bien d'ailleurs on est le
seul pays à débattre au parlement ces
questions et c'est très bien et si on
est d'ailleurs le seul pays à débattre
du plan déconfinement l'assemblée ou
dans un parlement
et c'est très bien on est le seul pays à
débattre de ce déconfinement à
l'assemblée et c'est très bien richard
richard wehrli c'est vrai que c'est faux
ça alors il faut savoir de quoi on parle
évidemment myriam si vous parlez des
mesures de déconfinement et du programme
de traçage en particulier pour l'instant
il n'y a pas eu d'autres débats dans des
parlements de pays européens voisins de
la france mais par contre il est
absolument fou de dire que la question
de l'état d'urgence sanitaire et que les
mesures liées à l'état d'urgence
sanitaire n'ont pas été discutés ces
faux dans le cas de l'allemagne
dès le 25 mars il y a eu un débat au
bundestag allemand madame merkel est
venue présenter son plan et un certain
nombre de mesures ont fait l'objet de
votes notamment les mesures économiques
c'est faux dans le cas de l'espagne où
la semaine dernière le premier ministre
pedro sanchez qui a comme vous le savez
une majorité extrêmement étroites et
bien il a remporté un vote par 178 voix
contre 75 sur encore une fois son plan
d'urgence et
une partie du déconfinement c'est faut
aussi du côté du parlement européen où
il y a eu un débat et le 16 avril en
présence de la présidente de la
commission européenne ou foulard
vandeurzen
alors tout est dans la nuance bien sûr
il faut il ne faut pas oublier les
questions de calendrier et au premier
abord les questions constitutionnelles
alors il n'y a qu'à très intéressant
c'est celui du royaume uni
vous savez que boris johnson lui même a
été contaminé par le cos vie 19
il a été en incapacité diriger le pays
il a repris ses fonctions récemment
c'est hier pour la première fois qu'il
s'est adressé à la chambre des communes
il a présenté son plan il a demandé la
prorogation de l'état d'urgence
sanitaire jusqu'au 1er juin et le vote
aura lieu aujourd'hui donc le 12 mai
dans le cas de l'italie c'est un petit
peu plus compliqué l'italie pays très
très fortement touchés alors là oui
le parlement s'est exprimé au début
c'était le 11 mars
ensuite la consultation parlementaire du
par le gouvernement est resté en sommeil
ça a d'ailleurs beaucoup énervé matteo
salvini qui dans la nuit du 27 au 28
avril a littéralement campé dans
l'hémicycle italien il n'a pas voulu en
sortir en demandant que le parlement
soit consulté donc encore une fois les
parlements européens sont sur le qui
vive
ils sont consultés après regardons sur
quoi exactement
si l'on parle du déconfinement on
pourrait plutôt dire que la france est
la première à avoir anticipé le débat
sur ces sujets merci beaucoup richard
aurore bergé sur quoi pourrait-on faire
mieux dans cette période qui va durer de
fait alors on n'est plus dans le
confinement
on voit bien que on va en parler
d'ailleurs un peu plus tard dans les
messieurs les députés se dé confino cia
on voit qu'ils le port du masque battre
obligatoire mais sur le fond là il va y
avoir des textes vous allez commencer
aussi à proposer
comment on peut faire mieux comment on
peut montrer au fond que ce que ce
parlement n'est pas sous cloche à la
question c'est quelles sont les
priorités qu'on se donne ya à la fois la
question de l'urgence donc là il ya des
dispositifs d'urgence d'accompagnement
pour tout simplement maintenir
l'activité ou pour ceux qui n'en avaient
plus maintenir des revenus donc ça a été
évidemment la première des choses et
après on a été beaucoup interrogée
pendant cette période de confinement sur
est ce qu'il y aura un jour d'après un
monde d'après ce que ce sera
extraordinairement
ferrand du monde avant tout dépend des
priorités qu'on va se donner tout dépend
aussi des priorités que les français
vont eux-mêmes à eux mêmes se donner
est-ce que la priorité sera le renouveau
du monde de travail dans l'édito on
parlait finalement de l'utilité sociale
des différents métiers est ce que en
effet un parlementaire est plus ou moins
utiles que tel ou tel média je pense
qu'il faut poser la question comme ça
non je crois un peu la réponse mais en
tout cas il ya cette question là sur le
renouveau du bon de travailler cette
plateforme logicielle par matthieu
orphelin le jour d'appeler ray avec
beaucoup d'autres députés et pas
uniquement des députés de l'opposition
dans la majorité également c'est une
plateforme pour au fond que les citoyens
puissent contribuer à la décision
peut-être un ça viendra peut-être une
décision ça ça sera utile
c'est au fond un peu de là comme ça je
ne peux pas répondre à la place de
solutions dans ses initiatives moi
j'attends par exemple que la
contribution citoyenne sur le climat
elles elles soient rendus parce que ça
c'est nouveau c'est à dire à un moment
qu'il ya un vrai une vraie logique de
consultation citoyenne et qui n'est
absolument pas initié et porté par tel
ou tel groupe politique
aujourd'hui je ne sais pas ce que cette
consultation va donner est ce que les
citoyens qui ont été consultés vont
vouloir changer leur orientation
justement regard de la crise que l'on
dit ou est-ce qu'au contraire ils vont
réaffirmer un certain nombre d'urgences
ça je pense que c'est intéressant et ça
devrait être une des priorités
évidemment qu'on se donne alors je vous
donne la parole sur quel projet de loi
dans ce monde d'après qu'ovide vous
souhaiteriez mais avant ça comme il ya
aussi des députés et la gueule le parti
socialiste qui a représenté la
république en marche mais il y en a
d'autres
que pense-t-il de ce parlement entendent
de coronavirus ils étaient une poignée
au départ dans l'hémicycle aujourd'hui
75 enfin 150
ils sont très nombreux à vouloir enfin
être 577 dans l'hémicycle écoutés mais
pas vous pouvez pas penser que
l'assemblée exerce ses pouvoirs
quand vous avez au maximum 75 députés
dans l'enceinte
et quand vous faites des commissions par
télétravail ou alors ça veut dire que
c'est plus la peine d'être autant que
nous sommes est certain c'est que depuis
le d
l'épidémie le parlement et sous cloche
on va le contester il ya une situation
d'urgence où il fallait donner des
pouvoirs exceptionnels au gouvernement
ça a été fait et je considère que cette
situation ne peut plus durer
il serait temps maintenant que nous
revenions un fonctionnement un peu plus
normale avec le temps qu'il faut
préserver se mettre à polémiquer parce
que on se réunirait pas comme on
voudrait on serait pas assis comme on
voudrait on serait pas nombreux comme en
voudrait c'est se plaindre quand partout
en france
il ya beaucoup de gens qui auraient bien
plus de motif que notre se plaindre
maurice bellot qu'est ce que vous
aimeriez qu'ils changent après c'est à
dire pas seulement sur le fond on entend
dire le président de la république
rien ne sera plus comme avant il faut
réinterroger le modèle de développement
je vais changer enfin moi le premier est
ce qu'il pourrait y avoir des majorités
nouvelles des alliances nouvelles d
unité nationale nouvelles sur certains
textes je suis un peu sceptique comme ce
temps le président de la république que
dire qu'il va être l'alternative à
lui-même bon on verra tout cas il ya un
certain nombre d'exigences comportera
dans l'évocation du monde après je ne
sais pas qu'elle prendra la forme de la
consultation de la concertation
j'entendais re verger dire il faut qu'on
regarde ce que propose la convention
citoyenne et je trouve que la forme est
intéressante
il faudra probablement en tirer des
conclusions pour la généraliser la mort
d'eyadema mais c'est sur la rénovation
thermique des bâtiments et d'ailleurs
j'ai retrouvé beaucoup d'éléments d'une
proposition de loi socialiste que nous
avions déposé et qui a été écarté par
par la majorité
voilà redéposer peut-être que il ya eu
des conversions et qu' elle pourra à
prospérer je crois que c'est utile parce
que nous ne sommes pas dans une
trajectoire qui nous permettent
d'atteindre la neutralité carbone en
donc voilà un certain nombre de sujets
et celui il ya la réforme
institutionnelle il faudra qu'elles
viennent et puis il ya un certain temps
ce n'est qu'elle viendra quand même
après ce qu'il fasse je pense que il y a
trois sujets c'est la question
climatique écologique qu'aient
absolument majeur je crois que la
question la lutte contre les inégalités
on avait formulé des propositions sur
les écarts de rémunération de
l'entreprise sur le partage de la valeur
ajoutée sur la progressivité de l'impôt
sur la contribution des plus riches
et puis la question démocratique de la
pratique démocratique intéressant pour
terminer ces trois sujets le social les
inégalités la question institutionnelle
et la question climatique vous pourriez
vous retrouver dans une une large
majorité et au delà des frontières
désintégrer décor marche difficile de
dire qu'on souhaite pas que la question
de la démocratie de l'écologie ou des
solidarités ne soit pas posé la question
par exemple des inégalités ça dépend
aussi par quel angle on considérait ce
qu'on considère par l'entrée sur le
monde du travail
est-ce qu'on le considère au regard des
inégalités éducatives culturelles qui
ont été non seulement révélé mais
accentué malheureusement par la crise en
disant que c'est par là que tout doit
commencer la question énergétique est ce
qu'on considère par les entreprises ou
par l'enjeu notamment de
l'accompagnement comme vous le dites sur
la rénovation thermique est l'un des
angles qui aussi d'ailleurs avant que
les taxes sur les actions de sur la
question c'est pas de discours mais
derrière moi j'ai plus hauts revenus en
france est en hausse et déjà le cas la
wii et plus hauts revenus contribuent
dans notre pays l'impôt est progressif
est ce que vous êtes prêt à rétablir
lisf non contribution bah voilà vous
voyez je le donnerai droite gauche non
mais je sais pas si c'est une gauche ou
une droite quand je vous parle par
exemple la question éducative culturelle
bien sûr le sujet du cas type de
monsieur blanc coeur et puis le le le le
vrai sentiment là on voit qu'il ya des
lignes de faille ou encore kid des
moeurs irrégulière au sein des dents
serrées vous parlez aux vauréens
victoire et la question de la
représentation des batteries cette
question des inégalités tout cas je
crois qu'on est d'accord là dessus
vivement qu'on reverra t on ce qu'on
sorte de la cloche
merci merci alors les deux d'être venu
au fond nous des confiné en direct un
pour cette reprise tentation
merci stéphane on se retrouve des
smartphones il va falloir revenir quand
même j'espère plus tôt sera le mieux
bien de leur autour du débat bon
d'accord
cette question à présent les politiques
ont-ils le droit à l'erreur dans notre
pays la france n'est pas la moins bien
classée dans la gestion de la crise en
nombre de victimes par exemple et
pourtant le français les français
apparaissent comme les citoyens les plus
critiques d'europe comment l'expliquer
avant d'accueillir à nouveau invités
voyez le sujet de clément pernot le
désinfectant ça assomme le virus en une
minute
donald trump qui suggérait d'injecter du
désinfectant dans le corps des malades
du coït 19 conserve 49% d'opinions
favorables dans son pays
je sers énormément demain et je vais
continuer de serrer des mains c'est
important mais boris johnson qui
persistait avoir serré des mains alors
que la crise sanitaire s'installer en
europe reste un bon premier ministre
pour 46% des britanniques
la gestion parfois erratique de la
pandémie par certains dirigeants ne
semblent pas toujours se payer cash dans
l'opinion des dirigeants comme trump ou
johnson bénéficient de phénomènes qu'on
connaît traditionnellement en période de
crise qui sont des phénomènes de
rassemblement autour du drapeau comme on
dit et qui font que en période de crise
beaucoup de citoyens ont tendance à
soutenir leur gouvernement
quelles que soient les décisions prises
par ce qu'il considère que c'est un
moment charnière
mais le phénomène ne marche pas pour
tout le monde
nous sommes en guerre toute l'action du
gouvernement et du parlement doit être
désormais tournés vers le combat contre
l'épidémie perceptible en début de crise
l'unité nationale s'est très vite
effritée en france seuls 34% des
français estiment que le gouvernement a
été à la hauteur de la situation
contre 51% pour le reste de l'europe
principale critique le gouvernement
n'aurait pas été suffisamment clair
et n'aurait pas dit toute la vérité une
crise de confiance s'est clairement
installée je crois qu'il ya une raison
particulière et qui d'ailleurs est assez
renforcée par la perception qu'ont les
français de cette crise
on est dans un pays où rôle de rita est
bien plus important dans l'esprit des
citoyens qu'ils n'avaient ailleurs les
français attendent beaucoup plus de
l'état que nous réserve en attente de
leur état ou que les britanniques nathan
devrait pas et en même temps il ya un
sentiment très fort en france que l'état
est inefficace et n'est pas capable
d'améliorer les choses de régler les
situations
cette défiance les français vont jusqu'à
se l'appliquer à eux-mêmes ils sont 61 %
à estimer que leurs concitoyens se sont
mal comportés pendant la crise sanitaire
quand cela rejoint garrigue bonsoir et
merci d'être en direct avec nous sur ce
plateau vous êtes historien professeur
d'université à orléans et président du
comité d'histoire parlementaire en face
de vous arié alimi bienvenus vous êtes
avocat au barreau de paris bonsoir vous
avez déposé plusieurs plaintes devant la
cour de justice de la république à
l'encontre de plusieurs ministres vous
allez nous expliquer dans le détail qui
est en cause
est ce que vous attendez un parent c'est
par ces procédures
et puis par webcam ce soir depuis le
vaucluse nous sommes avec le sociologue
jean viard bonsoir merci d'être avec
nous très belle bibliothèque on découvre
comme ça un petit peu les intérieurs et
les les bureaux de chacun merci d'être
avec nous enfin notre chroniqueur et
historien spécialiste des états unis
françois durpaire est ce qu'il est avec
nous françois gilas or si ils arrivent
superbe on a tout de suite
françois partons de sondages si vous le
voulez bien jean garrigues 62% des
français qui ne sont pas satisfaits de
la gestion du coronavirus par le
gouvernement seulement 24 % en allemagne
39 % au royaume-uni à leur concert ait
eu des défaillances beaucoup d'erreurs
de la part de boris johnson 45% en
italie dans un pays qui a été dépassé au
départ par cette crise il vous
surprennent ou pas ces chiffres n'ont
ils me surprennent pas on pourrait se
demander pourquoi effectivement les
français sont plus sévères
envers un certain nombre d'erreurs qui
ont été commises par par le gouvernement
et par le président la république erreur
de stratégie de communication réelle
parce que si l'on compare avec quelqu'un
comme boris johnson ou avec donald trump
est encore plus on peut dire que
finalement on s'en sort on se sort pas
trop mal mais ce serait faire
abstraction de notre rapport au pouvoir
ça a été évoqué dans le petit reportage
qui est un rapport extrêmement critique
c'est pas quelque chose qui est
aujourd'hui mon c'est que les deux tiers
des français ne font plus confiance dans
leurs élites politiques dans leurs
députés dans leurs ministres ya un
phénomène spécifique qui est dû à la
personnalité des manuels macron je pense
que l'image de président des riches et
de président coupé du peuple
quelle image initiale liée lisf etc
la suppression de l'isf est une image
qui colle à la peau de d'emmanuel macron
et une deuxième image que très
habilement le l'opposition a beaucoup
utilisé ces derniers temps c'est l'image
d'amateurisme d'ailleurs assez entretenu
par un certain nombre d'erreurs de
communication de de plusieurs ministres
y compris d'ailleurs de la porte parole
du gouvernement
cette image d'amateurisme elle est aussi
quelque chose qui qui pèsent sur sur
l'allemagne
et puis il ya quelque chose de plus
fondamental c'est une période de
d'inquiétude profonde pour pour les
français d'inquiétude par rapport à nos
pas simplement à l'avenir immédiat mais
par rapport à ce que va devenir la
nation france nation qui a perdu sa
puissance sinon qu'est devenue une
puissance marginal il ya quelque chose
que les français du g2 l'époque du
général de gaulle ou de georges pompidou
qui croyaient encore à cette puissance
ont totalement perdu aujourd'hui et
d'autres confond avec la france est un
sentiment du déclin français tout ça
voyez un gala merkel peut y avoir un
sentiment de déclin d'un pays qui
vieillit etc mais il ya l'expérience
dans le gala merkel
emmanuel macron il n'a pas cette
expérience il est il est l'homme du
dégagisme il est l'homme qui apparaît
comme un amateur ceux qui sont autour de
lui ne sont pas tous des vieux routiers
de la politique
tout ça ça joue pour expliquer à quel
point il ya une sévérité
alors vous vous disiez du conjoncturel
et de la personnalité des manuels macron
la défiance qui étaient là on se
souvient de la réforme des retraites des
gilet jaune il ya aussi du structurel
jean viard et je me tournerai vers vous
juste après harry ali mi janvier
vous avez peut-être plus comme moi cet
article dans politico de john lichfield
qui explique que même en des temps
exceptionnels la france trouve de
nouvelles façons d'être exceptionnelle
c'est un article intitulé l'étrange
défaite de la france que toi des
français ne lâche pas macron sur sa
réponse à l'épidémie
et il explique que c'est en partie une
question de caractère national de sens
de l'exception française
est ce que vous êtes d'accord je suis
d'abord assez d'accord avec ce qu'a dit
jean garrigues sur la situation qu'on
connaît c'est vrai qu'on est un pays
sans doute eu fait avec des diversités
profonde dont le succès du livre de
gérer la société d'archipel c'était pas
le titre exact mais nous avons touché
l'archipel français disaient beaucoup
parlé ça renvoyait bien une certaine et
et puis faut se rappeler que le
président mâcon était déjà très
impopulaire avant et quand ce qu'on
vient de vivre donc ça n'a pas aidé tous
ces éléments se marrer et puis j'ai
aussi que c'est vrai qu'on a quand même
le sentiment d'avoir un appareil d'état
extrêmement puissant et finalement c'est
plus performants excusez moi l'histoire
des masques c'est totalement lamentable
personnes qu'on a présenté des excuses
sur le fait qu'on ait melloul khaled
immobile et faire des stocks
c'est quand même je ne dis pas que ça
aurait changé fondamentalement les
choses parce que je pense que le seuil
des complexes sergent n'a pas dit aux
gens écouter on a fait le tour arrive
effectivement les stocks de masques en
les enlever on nous prend un peu pour
des envies donc on les infantilise les
j'aime pas trop l'image mais je pense
qu'elle n'est pas entièrement mais
finalement qu'est ce qu'on voit en bois
et une révolte du monde hospitalier qui
marchent merveilleusement bien où
effectivement au four à d'abord on a
ouvert les cordons de la bourse
mais au fond ils sont un peu venir notre
gestion du conseil et celle record était
content donc un peu une prise de pouvoir
de la blouse
sur gestionnaire ou en tout cas un
rééquilibrage des rapports de force
parce que les sonneurs et quand même
toujours là et ça saoule et c'est bien
simple problème de même que les régions
c'est normal quand vous êtes en bretagne
de voltage désert fait qu'on vous dit
faut pas y aller vous gratter un peu la
tête en disant qu'est ce que je risque
donc cette espèce de sentiment fictif
d'égalité il renvoie pas notre idée
d'égalité le biais des qualités c'est
d'avoir le même risque d'être malade
il ya des territoires où il ya des
portes les territoires et les faits donc
tout ça si vous voulez moi j'ai
l'impression qu'on est face à l'usure
d'une représentation politique très
jacobine très dur aux pratiques au fond
et qui sont ceux sympa protégé par sa
parce qu'au fond ce qu'on à engagement
c'est de se sentir protégé on sait que
c'est dangereux on sait qu'il va y avoir
des morts
on n'y comprend pas grand chose le
gouvernement non plus mais je dirais qu
aucun gouvernement n'avait fait la
situation à voir donc on peut pas leur
reprocher non plus de découvrir le sujet
mais on a l'impression que ça branle
dans le manche et ça s'est fait de la
sécurité c'est à dire que la sphère
n'est pas tenue et dernière remarque pas
si l'avocat la parole à notre avocat
le choc est surprenant c'est que le
gouvernement ait des est contesté mais
les oppositions ne remontent pas la dre
crise politique c'est celle normalement
dans une démocratie quand il ya un camp
thiero jeter les gens soutiennent les
autres on se défoule onu rond dans la
rue on n'y a pas le gouvernement et on
vote
et puis ça redonne du choc la démocratie
c'est quasiment acquis que dire de la
crise à vouloir d'une démocratie anémiée
et je trouve ça extrêmement inquiet tôt
je me tourne vers vous arié alimi
l'avocat que vous êtes
on attend trop de l'état et en même
temps on lui fait pas confiance
avant de vous expliquer quelles actions
en justice vous mener en ce moment
exemple je vous donne un autre un autre
news tribune de deux d'alain duhamel
cette fois ci nous ne sommes pas le pays
des cartes nous sommes le pays d'astérix
nous n'aimons pas les pouvoirs aucun
pouvoir et en particulier pas le pouvoir
politique
nous n'aimons pas être gouvernés ni
semences et moins encore bousculé et
sûrement pas dupe et le français et le
citoyen le plus critique d'europe
ce n'est pas un défaut mais aussi le
moins gouvernable c'est totalement faux
je partage pas l'opinion dessus du ml je
partage la dichotomie entre les
explications à la fois structurelle et
conjoncturelle structurelle et je pense
qu'il faut vraiment faire un retour sur
notre fonctionnement institutionnel et
constitutionnel
effectivement j'y viendrai mais les
plaintes sont aujourd'hui les plaintes
pénales sont aujourd'hui devenus
peut-être le dernier moyen d'expression
citoyenne
malheureusement devrais je dire mais
c'est un peu ça pour quoi parce que
quand on y réfléchit la vème république
c'est un régime présidentiel vous
parliez tout à l'heure de l'angleterre
c'est un régime parlementaire avec une
expression citoyenne plus importante dès
lors avec un avec une opposition qui
s'exprime alors même que la majorité est
innovant coup injustice c'est
l'expression ultime d'un contre-pouvoir
qui n'existe plus c'est ça l'idée qui
n'a peut-être jamais existé qui s'en va
jamais existé même avant la crise mais
quand vous y réfléchissez vous avez
d'abord un régime présidentiel vous avez
le parlement qui lorsqu'il ya une
majorité ne s'exprime pas véritablement
puisqu'il est l'expression de l'exécutif
vous avez une autorité judiciaire et non
pas un pouvoir judiciaire qui n'a pas
véritablement de pouvoir et en ce moment
pendant l'été venant sanitaires et elle
est complètement confiné voir morte et
vous avez un conseil d'état on l'a vu
pendant l'état d'urgence sanitaire
mais depuis l'époque bonapartiste depuis
depuis le napoléon bonaparte puisqu'il
c'est à ce moment là qu'il a été créé
pour justifier l'action de l'état ne
fait que justifier l'action de l'état
voire même sollicite par exemple une
réduction du contrôle parlementaire on
l'a vu dans le cadre de l'état d'urgence
sanitaire est dans la loi d'abrogation
le débat précédent vous avez alors
expliquez nous pourquoi aujourd'hui vous
en venez apporter au fond la cause vous
allez nous dire de qui est ce que ce
sont des associations est ce que ce sont
des syndicats ce que ce sont des
victimes directes devant les plus hautes
courant c'est la cour de justice de la
république c'est bien ça pour des
actions commises ou non commises par par
des ministres du gouvernement
il ya eu des plaintes qui ont été
déposées par la cour de justice de la
république ce ne sont pas les plaintes
que nous avons déposées je représente à
la fois le collectif intérieur gens ce
qui est un collectif de le personnel
soignant est également la cgt la
fédération chanter de la cgt qui ont
tous deux déposé plainte
ces plaintes ont été déposées devant le
procureur auprès du procureur de la
république de paris
ce sont les plantes contre x qui ne vise
pas spécifiquement ni des ministres ni
personne le but ce n'est pas de l'inde
contre il est très bien j'en ai pardonné
précision pourquoi ne pas déposer devant
la cour de justice de la république
parce que justement là encore on parler
de l'absence de contre-pouvoir c'est un
organe hybride qui est composé à la fois
de politique et de juge et on se rend
compte que finalement le la il ya très
peu de possibilités d'obtenir ne serait
ce qu'une enquête donc procureur de la
république pôle de santé publique de
paris avec une ouverture d' enquête
pourquoi parce que en france
pourquoi la particularité de la france
et bien tout simplement parce qu'il ya
eu beaucoup de fautes commises dans la
gestion de cet état dieu de cette crise
et donc vous établissez quoi des chefs
d'inculpation précis ya quatre chefs qui
sont visés vous avez d'abord
l'abstention à prendre les mesures et à
combattre un sinistre
la deuxième chose c'est les délits non
intentionnels à savoir homicide
involontaire parce que beaucoup de
soignants sont morts du fait de cette
contamination et violences involontaires
également ce sont des délits non
intentionnels vous en avez une dernière
qui est la mise en danger de la vie
d'autrui par des mois mais pour ceux qui
ne connaissent pas bien la procédure
pénale
c'est l'état x mais qu'est ce qui se
passe après vous plaidez échos qui qui
rembourse ras jdir qui dédommage si vous
gagnez on peut engager la responsabilité
de l'état devant les juridictions
administratives
ce n'est pas le choix que nous avons
fait parce que elles sont un peu
sclérosé et elles suivent l'état
aujourd'hui on a choisi de demander une
ouverture d' enquête pour déterminer les
faute non intentionnelle négligence
manquements qui ont été commises dans le
cadre de la gestion de cette crise et
quand je parle de choses
si je parle notamment de l'absence de
masques la destruction des masques et de
l'absence de stocks de réserves
disponibles pour ne serait ce que pour
les soignants pour qu'il puisse soigner
mais également de l'absence de tests
alors même que l' oms avait depuis le 24
janvier tester tester pardonnez moi oui
je vais un peu vite parce que le temps
presse un peu d'un mot c'est légitime le
juge plutôt que les urnes parce que
c'est ça le vrai débat de fond on peut
toujours sanctionné dans les urnes un
président de la république qui sera
amené ou pas à se représenter c'est pas
incompatible vous avez une tribune
d'olivier beaud dans le monde qui dit on
ne devrait pas aller vers la
responsabilité pénale on devrait
conserver la responsabilité politique
les deux existent elles ne sont pas
incompatibles et c'est la raison pour
laquelle on considère que il
faute qui doivent être sanctionnés c'est
dit je voudrais qu'on se tourne à
présent vers françois françois durpaire
est votre regard sur des états unis
comment expliquer françois qu'après les
boulettes et les déclarations
surréalistes de donald trump
il ne dévisse pas dans les sondages le
président américain alors il dévisse
quand même un petit peu dans les
salaires et notamment david jours assure
ben oui c'est ce qui suppose que même
dans ce cas il des fils quand même
notamment les états clés pourquoi vais
d'abord confusion vous parliez des
manuels macron confusion de la parole
présidentielle aux états unis très très
clair vous avez aujourd'hui aujourd'hui
anthony fauci automne il faut si vous le
connaissez maintenant c'est le chef de
la santé de la maison blanche
l'expert de d'un train qui aujourd'hui
devant le sénat tease et il ne faut pas
des confiné parce qu'on va avoir de
nouvelle vague c'est à dire exactement
l'inversé de ce que dit donald trump
depuis des semaines et des semaines et
il disait d'ailleurs le bilan de 80
mille morts c'est un bilan sans doute
sous-estimé
c'était une déclaration faite au sénat
alors pas très rassurante pour les
américains il était lui même confiné à
distance parce que suspicion de kobe de
10,9 au sein de la maison blanche
vous parliez de l'opinion publique
française opinion publique américaine
elle est très très simple vous avez d'un
côté des républicains le parti d'aidé
confiné 1 ce qui ne porte pas de masque
au congrès par exemple et puis le parti
des démocrates le parti des confiné ce
qu'ils disent mais qu'america steyn
games vous savez le fameux slogan de
trains qu'il leur visait en disant faire
de l'américain pays à nouveau qui a la
santé et vous avez entre les deux
quelques indépendants qui vont compter
les points alors c'est un peu morbide
il ya des états rouge alors les états
rouge aux etats unis c'est d'état
républicain
ceux qui ceux des consignes on va
regarder le taux de mortalité
et puis il ya les états bleus les états
démocrate on va regarder aussi le taux
de mortalité et on comptera les points
en novembre prochain
celle que vivent 19 qui va faire
l'élection merci merci beaucoup
françois merci à vous d'avoir participé
à cet échange
il y aura d'autres débats on était
obligés d'avancer c'est l'heure de
retrouver thomas des prêts merci à vous
jean viard depuis le vaucluse également
d'avoir été en duplex avec nous thomas
des prêts pour sa chronique quotidienne
ma journée à l'assemblée il nous raconte
au fond les députés autant du code vide
on retrouve tout de suite thomas devant
l'assemblée oui myriam depuis hier
l'assemblée ceux des consignes plus de
députés des règles plus strictes aussi
le port du masque est obligatoire dans
certains cas je vais vous raconter tout
ça dans ma journée à l'assemblée des
confiné depuis ce matin les députés
passe ici à l'accueil de l'assemblée
nationale par un point accueil santé ou
est distribué cette enveloppe
à l'intérieur deux masques et une paire
de gants pour pouvoir porter toute la
journée
c'est une bonne initiative pour vous oui
oui c'est très bien ça rend le travail
plus pratique même si on est tous plus
ou moins équipée de deux masques dans
nos activités habituelles ça vous
rassure vous de vous dire que vous allez
avoir des masses
moi ça me va moi j'ai eu le génie de ses
vis-à-vis des autres qu'on voit que
c'est plus c'est plus respectueux
vis-à-vis des eaux et le fait de
distribuer ces masques gratuitement aux
députés et non pas à toute la population
pour certains députés ça pose question
notamment dans les rangs des élus
communistes très bien pour les
personnels de l'assemblée nationale mais
en fait je pense que ça devrait être le
cas partout dans le pays qui a beaucoup
de gens encore pour qui ça va être un
budget très conséquent et donc je trouve
que la question de masques gratuits
devrait être une priorité pour le
gouvernement mais alors quelles sont les
nouvelles règles précisément à respecter
à l'assemblée et bien tout est enseigné
dans ce document myriam 56 pages le plan
de déconfinement de l'assemblée
nationale on y apprend le nombre de
députés qui peuvent être présents dans
l'hémicycle jusqu'à 150 contre moins de
10 au plus fort de la crise sur la
question du masque par exemple il est
obligatoire dans les espaces de
circulation comme pour notre collègue
cet après-midi les amendes un gala vous
voyez je n'ai vraiment pas l'habitude de
porter ce metz puisqu'il veut je le
remet correctement voilà et pour les
députés
le masque est donc obligatoire en
commission regardez les images
hier soir à l'assemblée mais pas dans
l'hémicycle comme cet après midi aux
questions au gouvernement
deux poids deux mesures donc on a voulu
demander à l'inde et questeur de
l'assemblée nationale vous savez ces
députés qui gère le fonctionnement de
l'assemblée
pourquoi il y avait une telle différence
bonjour la haine rossi expliquez-nous
pourquoi le masque est obligatoire en
commission et pas dans l'hémicycle
c'est parce qu'elles étaient les tout
simplement parce qu'en conditions
d'usagé une promiscuité une proximité
entre chaque député que vous n'avez pas
dans l'hémicycle dans l'hémicycle comme
nous sommes 150 au lieu de 577 nous
pouvons avoir trois à quatre mètres
entre chaque députés en commission ça
n'est pas possible non seulement des
petites salles les uns à côté des autres
sans possibilité d'avoir donc cette
distance nécessaire et le masque est
obligatoire en commission est ce que
vous vous savez quand est-ce qu'on
pourra retrouver 577 députés
je l'espère et nous l'espérons tous le
plus rapidement possible malheureusement
aujourd'hui la crise sanitaire
qui frappe notre pays mais aussi notre
assemblée nationale ne permet pas de
siéger à 577
nous pourrions prendre trop de risques
aussi bien aux députés qu'au personnel
donc nous assoupir ont de toute façon de
ces mesures si cela est possible d'en si
la situation le permet tait que dès que
possible mais aujourd'hui je crois qu'il
faut avancer prudemment et des consignes
et progressivement versés au dossier
et merci à thomas des prix qu'on
retrouve demain pour une nouvelle
chronique alors comme promis on va
terminer avec notre grand entretien
alors où plus d'un million d'élèves ont
retrouvé le chemin de l'école nous avons
donné la parole à un professeur
d'histoire-géographie en
seine-saint-denis il s'appelle yanis
rodern jours après l'école
regardez c'est une collection signée
françois chevré avec charlotte est pâle
et titre yeng wei n on est chez vous
c'est à iannis roder comme avec une
jolie jolie je regarde paris bonjour
yannick robert
bonjour et merci d'avoir accepté cet
entretien peut-être professeur
d'histoire géographie dans un collège de
seine-saint-denis
et puis vous êtes également le directeur
de l'observatoire de l'éducation au sein
de la fondation jean jaurès qui vient de
publier une offre que vous avez co
écrite avec salomé berlioux une détaillé
intitulé apprendre et enseigner par
temps de crise sanitaire regards croisés
ville campagne on va y revenir mais
d'abord racontez nous votre expérience
d'enseignant de ces deux mois
d'enseignement à distance
comment s'est déroulé s'est mise en
place l'école à la maison avec vos
élèves
pour dire la vérité elle s'est mise en
place tant bien que mal tant bien que
mal parce que d'abord même si on pouvait
s'attendre à une fermeture des écoles
après que l'italie a fermé les siennes
le 5 le 5 mars de mémoire on a quand
même été pris un petit peu
la part la surprise il a fallu
s'organiser très vite or effectivement
ce qu'on a vu très vite et ce qu'on
savait déjà c'est que les plateformes
numériques qui servent d'interface de
communication entre les familles et les
établissements scolaires
et bien ne sont pas toujours très
fréquenté et il ya des jeux parfois des
problèmes de code des problèmes de
connexion tout le monde n'est pas
équipée non plus à la maison pour
pouvoir correctement se connecter donc
il a fallu et ça a été la première chose
garder le contact avec les élèves et ont
gardé contact avec les élèves et bien je
crois que les profs en tout cas dans mon
établissement mais je ne sais que je
sais par ailleurs que ça s'est passé un
peu de la même manière tout le monde
s'est un petit peu débrouiller pour
essayer de garder le contact avec les
élèves c'est à dire qu'on s'est un petit
peu at il faut le dire quand même sur le
r gpd donc le règlement de la protection
sur la protection des données et on a
constitué des listes de whatsapp des
listes des mails liste des groupes des g
et c'est pascal et les enseignants n'ont
pas le droit d'accéder aux données
personnelles aux coordonnées précises
bien sûr que non c'est c'est
formellement interdit sauf que là il
fallait absolument garder contact avec
les élèves
or comme je voulais comme je voulais
dire des interfaces ne sont pas toujours
fréquenté le réflexe n'est pas
nécessairement acquis ni par les parents
ni par les élèves
donc il a fallu bricoler il a fallu
bricoler personnellement j'ai passé deux
ou trois jours à essayer de récupérer
des numéros de téléphone à droite à
gauche et a constitué mais mais mais il
est ministre
mais l'histoire sam egoo poids de sape
pour pouvoir travailler voilà et on a
commencé à travailler et on a commencé à
travailler avec ce que nous n'avions
jamais fait en réalité c'est à dire
faire des cours en visioconférence alors
racontez nous comment ça s'est passé
est ce que vous avez réussi à
transmettre est-ce que vous avez
enseigné
il ya des acquis d'apprentissage qui ont
été faits au cours de cette période je
l'espère et nous le verrons moment du
décompte vivement parce qu'on va revenir
là dessus évidemment on va laisser les
élèves avec ce qu'on a fait pendant le
décompte il ment on reviendra là-dessus
et c'est à ce moment là que je pourrais
éventuellement vous dire s'il ya eu des
acquis mais on a innové on a innové il a
fallu faire des cours à distance il a
fallu préparer des cours autrement parce
que faire des cours en visio ce n'est
pas la même chose que de faire des cours
en présentiel
les élèves ne branche pas leur caméra
donc moi je ne sais pas s'ils
comprennent ils comprennent pas donc
voilà il faut c'est très compliqué donc
moi ce que j'ai fait c'est que j'ai
donné un travail préparatoire
systématique avant chaque courant
visioconférence et puis les travaille
dessus
ce qui fait que voilà c'est fait de voir
deux fois les choses et insisté sur les
sur les choses après il ya une réalité
aussi
ce n'est pas parce que vous dites que
vous êtes un vilain cours en
visioconférence que tous les élèves sont
là loin de là loin de là puisque j'ai
plusieurs classes mais j'ai une classe
par exemple qui suit très régulièrement
avec 15 15 à 16 élèves présents sur 22
c'est un collège qui est classé en zone
d'éducation en réseau d'éducation
prioritaire avant qu'on a limité à 23
par classe quinze à seize présent
systématiquement à chaque cours
et puis j'ai une autre classe où c'est
beaucoup plus compliqué où j'ai eu par
exemple lundi dernier un cours à six
élèves
les voilà ça veut dire qu'il me manquait
les trois quarts pratiquement les trois
quarts des élèves trois quarts des
lèvres avec qui vous avez perdu
complètement le contact ou partiellement
non partiellement c'est à dire que dans
ces classes en général j'ai nous crache
g et l'établissement qui a cherché par
l'intermédiaire de ce qu'on appelle la
vie scolaire les cpe puis par les chefs
d'établissement d'entrer en contact avec
les familles et bien de certaines
familles n'ont pas répondu ou les élèves
ne répond pas là on peut estimer à un
quart voire peut-être 30 % des élèves
qui ont décroché kilos de plus signe de
vie ou alors qu'ils ne rendent aucun
devoir et qui ont complètement
scolairement décrocher c'est énorme
comme siffler je me permets de le
souligner vous l'expliquez comment alors
jeune explique d'abord
parce qu'on appelle la fracture
numérique évidemment j'ai des élèves qui
n'ont qui n'ont pas de connexion qui
n'ont pas de matériel
le collège a prêté du matériel mais les
connexions ne sont pas là certains de
mes élèves suivent sur un téléphone
portable
le téléphone portable c'est peut-être
celui de papa ou de maman qui peut en
avoir besoin
le manque d'équipements aussi parce que
quand on est resté un ordinateur et
qu'on a trois ou quatre frères et soeurs
qui sont eux aussi scolarisés et bien il
faut se partager l'ordinateur c'est très
compliqué tout cela ça c'est la première
chose
la deuxième chose c'est qu'il faut
savoir aussi que mes élèves ce sont les
enfants des gens qui sont en première
ligne aujourd'hui et qui assure la
logistique nous permettant à nous d'être
confiée ce sont les gens qui travaillent
dans les supermarchés dans la logistique
dans le transport et ces gens se lèvent
très tôt le matin et vont travailler
toute la journée ils laissent leurs
enfants seuls ce qui est logique et bien
ses enfants la journée
ils sont livrés à eux-mêmes et vous
faire écouter edouard philippe
il a eu une expression très forte au
sénat cinq mois de décrochage scolaire
pour des milliers de jeunes et des
dizaines de milliers de jeunes
c'est probablement une bombe à
retardement
le premier ministre un coût évidemment
les deux mois de vacances dans ces cinq
mois est ce que vous êtes d'accord
oui l'expression est très forte et je
crois que le premier ministre a raison
de tirer signal d'alarmé parce que
d'aucuns vous diront trois mois sans
apprentissage ce n'est pas grave
dans l'absolu ce n'est pas grave on est
d'accord quoique ça dépend de qui on
parle effectivement si on parle des
élèves qui ont leurs parents à la maison
avec qui prennent le petit déjeuner le
matin est acquis avec qui il discute
culture histoire
effectivement il n'y aura pas de
problème mais pour mes élèves qui ont
déjà un capital culturel qui n'est pas
celui des élèves de centre-ville où des
beaux quartiers
c'est trois mois sans et sans école ce
sera un handicap supplémentaire donc ce
n'est pas anodin et au delà de cela
c'est oublier que l'école notamment dans
ces quartiers populaires des grandes
agglomérations
ce n'est pas seulement le de
l'apprentissage c'est aussi le lieu
d'une sociabilité cellule c'est un lieu
repères qui donne des cadres qui donne
des limites dont nos élèves ont
absolument besoin et c'est aussi un lieu
d'ouverture sur le monde d'ouverture à
d'autres façons d'envisager de voir le
monde
quand on en vit dans des situations
compliquées dans des familles qu'ils
sont
parfois très fermé et bien l'école c'est
un lieu de respiration et ça c'est très
important
on vous sent très engagé personnellement
sur cette question du décrochage presque
en colère est ce que vous êtes un
fervent partisan pour ses élèves dans
votre département et pour tous les
élèves après tout de la réouverture des
écoles
alors donc dans l'absolu évidemment il
faut que les conditions sanitaires
soient absolument respecter c'est la
sécurité de tous est la première des
priorités
mais oui je suis un fervent partisan de
la reprise de l'école parce que encore
une fois ne pensez l'école qu'en termes
d'apprentissage et ne penser la
difficulté des familles quand tu es en
dettes financières
ça ne suffit pas ce n'est pas la
question en réalité la question c'est la
question de l'insertion sociale dans des
règles qui font société et c'est cela
que nous sommes en train de perdre
je discutais la semaine dernière avec
des éducateurs éducatrices qui suivent
quelques-uns de mes élèves et
l'éducatrice me disait avec grand une
véritable émotion dans la voix qui m'a
beaucoup touché nous sommes en train de
perdre 10 elle des dizaines de gamins
c'est une catastrophe
alors que pensez vous de tous vos
collègues enseignants qui explique bien
souvent pas tous qu'il n'est pas
possible de rouvrir les écoles d'urgence
sanitaire et la protection sanitaire
c'est extrêmement important
mais il ya une urgence il ya une urgence
sociale et je crois que je crois que
nous devons peut-être prendre exemple
sur les soignants qui ne ne se pose pas
la question de savoir si ils doivent
aller travailler ou pas c'est une
question d'urgence sanitaire eh bien je
crois que pour nous notamment dans les
territoires des 2 c de c2c de ses
banlieues des grandes agglomérations il
ya une urgence c'est une urgence sociale
je voudrais qu'on parle également des
campagnes et des jeunes ruraux un voulé
est évoqué tout à l'heure on dit
beaucoup que le confinement accélère les
inégalités la fracture numérique elle
pèse aussi lourdement pour ses élèves
ses étudiants qui vivent dans des zones
enclavées
quand on est dans une zone rurale
de montagne moyenne montagne par exemple
il ya des zones qui sont blanches qui ne
n'ont pas de connexion internet c'est ça
devient très compliqué pour
l'enseignement à distance de même pour
recevoir aujourd'hui les les devoirs et
les cours puisque tout est envoyé par
internet
quand ça fonctionne mal c'est très
compliqué donc il ya d'abord cette
fracture numérique qui est quand même
très importante
il ya ce sentiment d'isolement aussi un
qui a été relatée en parle dans l'étude
que nous avons fait avec avec salomé
berio et jérémy métier que vous avez
cités
c'est ce sentiment d'isolement de
solitude qui est très fort dans les
milieux dans les milieux ruraux et puis
il y a aussi ses difficultés liées
notamment à l'orientation et
l'orientation future parce que si dans
les grandes agglomérations vous avez
l'offre d'orientation qui n'est pas loin
grâce aux transports en commun même si
les transports en commun je comprends
que ça va être compliqué merlo néanmoins
l'offre l'offre et y est ici elle est
présente dans les territoires ruraux
l'offre peut être très lointaine donc en
fonction justement de cette réalité d'un
beaucoup d'élèves sont en train de de
renoncer à cette leur orientation qui a
redoublé ou kita à faire une orientation
par défaut
autre sujet le baccalauréat le bac qui
n'aura donc pas lieu pour la génération
2020 c'est le contrôle continu un don
qui tiendra lieu d'évaluation pour les
élèves de terminale et c'est une
première parce que même en mai 68 alors
que les lycées étaient bloqués il y a eu
un oral ça va peser sur ce diplôme si
symbolique et si décrié aussi par la
suite à votre avis alors sur l'oral
l'oral du bac de français mais c'est
l'oral effectivement un terminal qui est
qui est supprimé alors est-ce que ça
aura un impact
écoutez je ne le crois pas tout
simplement parce que il faut savoir
d'abord en 1968 le nombre de taux de
bacheliers étaient beaucoup beaucoup
plus faible qu'aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui le bac qu'ils soient
professionnels général ou technologique
on connaît les chiffres on est à plus de
plus de 85%
donc le bac aujourd'hui et c'est pour ça
qu'il eut cette réforme menée par le
ministre jean michel blanquer
il a été un petit peu déconsidérer il
est un petit peu dévalorisés donc je ne
suis pas sûr que le fait que ce bac
cette année ne soit pas subir un examen
final le change le regard que nous
avions globalement sur le baccalauréat
et les parents des parents qui ont dû
faire de la continuité pédagogique et
parfois qu'ils ont réalisés au fond la
difficulté de la tâche de l'enseignant
vous en sortez grandi à leurs yeux vous
pensez je l'espère je l'espère parce que
ce que nous avons pu ce que j'ai pu voir
ce que j'ai pu constater c'est le fort
engagement
d'une manière générale du corps
enseignant dans cette continuité
pédagogique avec les moyens qui étaient
les siens avec les déperditions que dont
nous avons parlé c'est une évidence mais
les professeurs se bat même encore
aujourd'hui pour rattraper les élèves
qui ont tendance à lâcher donc je vois
cet engagement je vois aussi quand
fonction des milieux on n'a pas
forcément la même attitude
je vois combien les parents sont
reconnaissants en seine-saint-denis du
travail fourni par les enseignants et
puis je peux voir aussi dans certains
quartiers parisiens par exemple des
associations de parents d'élèves qui se
plaignent que la prof machin ou le prof
bidule n'a pas n'a pas donné des devoirs
toutes les semaines et c'est sans tenir
compte de la réalité du confinement
c'est à dire que les enseignants ils ont
parfois aussi des enfants les enfants en
bazin qui doivent s'occuper
qu'est-ce qu'il faudra garder de toute
cette expérience ou surtout ne pas
conserver
moi je crois que la grande leçon c'est
c'est de travailler de faire travailler
de faire réfléchir sur justement les
urgences n d'urgence sanitaire et la
situation d'urgence sanitaire c'est à
dire la situation de confinement
rien ne nous dit que dans les 20 ans qui
viennent nous ne revivrons pas une
une expérience telle que celle ci donc
nous avons dans les établissements
scolaires des protocoles pour l'instant
10 des protocoles pour les risques
d'attentats depuis peu mais je crois
qu'il faut mettre en place des
protocoles d'urgence lié à l'urgence
sanitaire et ça veut dire par exemple
avoir connaissance de l'équipement de
chaque famille du lien de chaque famille
avec le numérique et que les
établissements soient équipés pour venir
en aide à ceux qui n'ont pas les moyens
de s'équiper ont finalement d'un mot
rien ne remplace le contact physique
entre l'enseignant et l'élève
je crois que cette période de l'école
l'école en confinement l'école à la
maison a mis un terme à la discussion
sur les bienfaits du numérique dans le
pédagogique
voilà je crois que rien ne vaut la
présence la présence et le lien physique
que l'on vu qu'on a dans les classes
parce que c'est là que je construis l'
échange pédagogique c'est là que te
construis l'enseignement le numérique
est un plus mais ça ne peut être qu'un
plus
merci infiniment merci et yanis trader
[Musique]
voilà le jour d'après c'est à retrouver
désormais tous les soirs dans cette
émission qui s'achève ainsi tout de
suite à votre soirée documentaire à
demain sur la cité
[Musique]